皆さん竹とんぼをしたことは
ありますでしょうか
子供の頃なら多分やったと思うんですけども
竹とんぼって言うのは基本的に なんか
こーやって こーやったら 飛んでく
って ゆーのが「たけとんぼ」なんですけど
ま、それのちょっとおしゃれ版
を買ってみました。
こちら
まー、ぱっと見
ちょっと 竹とんぼ とは言い難いんですけども
一葉、やってる事は完全に竹とんぼ　なんですよ
-スカイコプター-ってゆー みたいです
スカイコプター（発音よく
ロケットの様に空高く飛び、クルクル回りながら降りてきますと
飛ばし方が なんか
こーゆーパチンコみたいなのがあって
これにこーやって
バンッ！って飛んだら
ロケットの様に飛んでいく  と
ゆーやつでございます。
やります！
あ、もぅ、こーゆー パターン
一番俺が嫌なやつ
わ、すごい なんか・・・
（パタパタ・・・）
あぃ
なには
ともあれ
高く飛べば 僕もテンションが上がるんで
高く飛んでほしい って 一心で一瞬で作りましょう
思ったより ちゃっちくて不安なんですけど
これで、こーやれば
パチンッ（ゴムの音
飛んでくと
けっこう伸びるから 期待はできますね
なるほど、こーゆーフックがあって
このフックをこのゴムにかけて
こーやって、うにゃって・・・
ばぁｓh(意味不明
フックをゴムにかけてこーやって 伸ばして手を離すと
上に飛んでくって やつですね
（天井に当たって）バチンッ！！
はい、とゆーわけで外に来ました
家の中では飛ばせなかったので ちょっと外で
これを飛ばしていきたいと思います
（きらりん☆彡）
いきます
（-走る足音-）
シュンッ！（飛ばした）
はっはｗｗ（笑うはじめ）
ま、普通の竹とんぼであんなに飛ぶことはないと思うんで
これでも十分すごいんですけども
もぉぉぉぉちょっと
はいこちら ロケット花火でございます
手を使った時よりパチンコを使った時の方が
飛ぶということが 分かりました
この竹とんぼ見て分かる通り 軽量化されてるんですうよ
すごい軽いからパチンコでバッって飛ばしても すごい飛ぶって事がわかったんで
もっっと飛ぶんじゃないかと ゆーことで
今回竹とんぼにロケット花火を付けて
ぶっぱなしてみようと思います
パチンコでけっこう飛んじゃうんで
ロケット花火でどこまで行けるかが
今回の見どころだと思います
では 行こう
作っていくよ
まず用意する物
こーゆー感じでロケット花火を付けて
ピシィってなって ブァァァって飛んでく
イメージです
ガムテープで付けてきます
こー飛んで 飛ぶとこまで飛んだら
こーやって 降りてきます
じゃぁ・・・
いきます いきます いきます
（ヒュヒュヒュン）
シュッ（ロケット花火が飛ぶ音）
パァン！（ロケット花火の爆発音）
火力が足りないので次3つ付けてやってみましょう
多すぎてもタイミングが合わなので
たぶん三つくらいが丁度いい量だと思います
どうどうどうどう
これで行ってきます
はい 次はもう三発まとめて入れてあります
では、いきます
シュッ（ロケット花火が飛ぶ音）
シュッ（二発目
どでどでどでどで
ぴーぽぴぱぽーぴー
ぴぽぴぴー　ぽぴぴぽーぴー
ぴぽぱぴー ぽーぴぴ
どぅでぃでぃどぅーでぃーでぃー
ぽぴぽぴぽひぽぴ
ぽぽぽぽん
シュッ（ロケット花火が飛ぶ音）
パァン！
ばーい